our most complete picture of life on
earth is coming into focus a stunning
new NASA time-lapse video comes crams 20
years into just a few minutes it is
helping scientists learn a lot more
about global warming and how the earth
is changing chip Reid is at NASA's
Goddard Space Center in Greenbelt
Maryland chip good morning well good
morning the scientists we talked to
called this place paradise for geeks and
what they're geeking out about now is
that new toy for studying what's
happening to the oceans and what it
means for us it's one-of-a-kind it's
never been done before and so being able
to capture land ocean atmosphere ice
over 20 years together it's insanely to
raise your bill NASA wants the first of
three satellites in 1997 allowing them
to track life on Earth through 20 years
of satellite imaging bottom line what
are you seeing the planet getting warmer
over these 20 years
absolutely nasa oceanographer dr. jeremy
Wardell says the data help show how our
planet is changing what are you seeing
in terms of water levels ocean levels
generally speaking ocean levels are
rising now they they rise slowly it's
like watching Ice Cube's melt in a glass
of soda what's causing these changes in
color are changes in gazillions of
microscopic creatures called
phytoplankton you love these little guys
I'm sorry we do i I do love these guys
that means they're just first they
useful to the society to feed as they
give us oxygen but they're just so
beautiful the tiny ocean organisms dr.
ivona set inerts studies along with
plants on the ground pull carbon dioxide
out of the air and help make human life
possible how many phytoplankton cells
are in this bottle would you guess I
would say 20 Millions these building
blocks of life are at the bottom of the
food chain and Satanist says as they
change sodas earth's ecosystem it's
really cool this data set is powerful
because tell us what's happening now
what happen in past but also what's
gonna happen in future
yes it's complicated but one way to
think about all this is that scientists
are keeping track of all of these
phytoplankton in the oceans
so that they have kind of an early
warning system on what's happening to
the earth as it heats up and to help
them do their jobs even better they're
sending up another satellite tomorrow
all right chip it may be complicated but
you can certainly feel the enthusiasm
from dr. Jeremy and and dr. Ilona I like
that and you can see how the world is
the echo system is so connected yes
insanely cool ship could must be a
professor Jeffrey there you know I mean
that's excellent chip thank you
professor Reed you're looking good thank
you - thank you very much